you know earlier i mentioned
in the reference to sunlight i talked
about dopamine and testosterone
testosterone has a huge number of
effects in the body and it's sibling
molecule if if you will
dihydrotestosterone is perhaps the more
dominant androgen in human
okay uh you know there are pharmacologic
versions of this right oxandralone
anovar i'm not suggesting people take
those right what i'm talking about is
the dht you make naturally very powerful
androgen it's converted from
testosterone into you get dht in a
conversion of testosterone to dht
through a molecule called 5 alpha
reductase anytime you hear ace it's
almost always an enzyme aces basically
you know
protein ace
okay
so
dht uh it's going to cause some male
pattern baldness so this
your widow's peak
your widow's peak yep yeah what was it
widow's peak sure uh tell you
my my now elaborating widow speed that's
dihydrotestosterone causes beard growth
on the face and causes male pattern
balance has inverse effect on the scalp
and on the face like it has other
effects
strength etc
the testosterone molecule and the
dopamine molecule bear a very close
relationship so if somebody pushes
pushes pushes really hard wins wins wins
yes that will increase testosterone
winning increases testosterone losing
decreases testosterone in all venues
yeah so they look at this with with day
traders win win win win win more money
they get more tests out they're losing
okay now here's the interesting thing
i had an episode of the podcast with the
great robert sapolsky wrote why zebras
don't get ulcers the trouble with
testosterone etc let's talk about the
effects of testosterone and dht in the
brain the main effect of these androgens
in the brain is to make effort feel good
because of the way that testosterone and
dht bind to receptors and activate
certain components of the amygdala we
always think of the amygdala as a fear
center but it's a threat detection
center and it has a lot of different
parts including parts that allow you to
be forward center of mass in response to
pressure
so
am i suggesting people take exogenous
testosterone no that's a personal choice
that people can explore on their own if
they want to do that but if you've been
pushing pushing pushing and winning
winning or just pushing really hard and
then you've experienced that crash
a lot of people need some time to
recover in order to be able to come back
and be able to work hard again but
here's what's really interesting not
only does testosterone make effort feel
good effort increases testosterone so
this is the athlete or the student who's
like i don't want to do it i don't want
to do anything getting into some degree
of forward center of mass i always say i
think i picked this up from a team guy
it's very team guy language you can
either be back on your heels flat-footed
or forward center of mass on anything
getting into that forward center of mass
mental orientation can start to trigger
some of the pathways related to these
hormones and these neuromodulators what
you don't want to do is start using a
lot of exogenous factors caffeine or a
lot of things outside of you in order to
try and create those states because then
you're going to further deplete your
dopamine and so on
when i think you went on rogan at one
point and i overheard a person i
listened to a portion of the
conversation where you said you had um
been working really hard and then you
went on vacation and then you got sick
yeah so this is interesting that's the
autonomic nervous system that's happened
to me like
numerous times okay so so there's a very
clear explanation for that in a very
simple remedy although it's not obvious
which is why many people experience this
many people experience studying for
finals and then it ends getting sick
taking care of a loved one
round the clock
the person either gets better or
sometimes dies or whatever it is
and then
the caretaker gets sick why is that well
we always hear that stress compromises
the immune system
nothing could be further from the truth
stress activates the immune system think
about it how would your immune system
your spleen and your other immune organs
of the body know when it's under
pressure well
you could have some foreign bacteria or
virus in your body but when you are in a
mode of go go the molecule adrenaline
triggers the release of killer b cells
and t cells from the spleen
it's when you relax now you need to get
your sleep but it's when you finally
experience that
symmetric swing back of the sea sauce
here go go go go go boom and then you
completely relax and you're hanging out
with me and all of a sudden you get the
sniffle and the rest of the thing this
is there's a beautiful study done by
that was done in response to none other
than wim hof believe it or not there's a
really beautiful quality scientific
study published in the proceedings of
the national academy of sciences where
they had two groups of people one group
meditated the other group did wim hof
type breathing so what we call in the
laboratory cyclic hyperventilation so
inhale exhale inhale exhale 25 times
forceful inhales and forceful exhales
then hold your breath lungs empty for 15
seconds repeat for about three rounds
what does that do why do you heat up
adrenaline it's a generic thing it's
adrenaline you could have gotten into an
ice bath adrenaline you could you have
someone shouting your face
adrenaline it's just adrenaline what
what did they do they injected both
groups of people with e coli
injecting them with e coli one group
gets nauseous vomiting and feels sick
the group that does this cyclic
hyperventilation wim hof also called
tumor-type breathing
far fewer symptoms if any including
lack of fever
so why well they were able to combat the
the attack of this bacteria so if you're
coming off of a hard bout of work
and you're starting to relax into
vacation you would be wise to still get
into some cold water you would be wise
to still do some cyclic hyperventilation
breathing
certainly don't do those at the same
time a number of people actually have
died doing cyclic hyperventilation and
then doing breath holds because when you
exhale a lot of carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide is the trigger to breathe this
is really important if if you do
hyperventilation
and then you hold your breath you can do
a much longer breath hold than you could
if you just started off without having
done that why that you don't take
breaths because of a need for oxygen
although you do need that you take
breaths because of a buildup of carbon
dioxide triggers these brain stem
neurons which have you do the gasp
reflex
okay well if you dump all your carbon
dioxide and you're not a skilled
uh free diver like markelly or somebody
like that who really understands that
what happens is you're swimming along
you're like wow i can really hold my
breath down here a long time lights out
actually i'm aware of a few people in
the military community who who've
dabbled with
wim hof tumor type breathing and have
died and
not it's not good i think it's not
allowed basically it's not certainly not
encouraged from what i understand
so do it on land away from water
and the idea here is that adrenaline
protects us
you don't want it cascading out of
control so that you can't sleep you want
to use things like non-sleep deep
breaths and the appropriate timing of
light and exercise etc to be able to
sleep well at night to reset all these
systems
but
if you go too quickly from go go go go
to complete relaxation your immune
system your defense system will crash
too
and so you're not going to be able to
fight off even even the smallest or the
you know the pettiest of viruses in
bacteria that's when you get the sniffle
you get sick you're like i'm finally
resting what's going on
so you can taper out of those high
intensity phases there are actually you
know guys in the teams other
now that i think are aware of this and
are starting to think about this and for
various effects but in the mind
testosterone makes effort feel good
adrenaline puts us into a mode of
readiness dopamine puts us into a mode
of motivation and then there's the
mirror side of all this which are the
neurochemicals that broadly define
promote relaxation and parasympathetic
activation and those come under the
names that you probably heard them
before like serotonin
oxytocin and the hormone prolactin
serotonin and oxytocin are molecules
that make us feel good make us feel
soothed
not in response to things that we're
motivated to go get but in response to
what we already have so this might sound
a little woo but you know if you sit
there and do a gratitude practice
or you hang out with your dog and your
kids or you eat a meal right you're
nourishing yourself with food that you
are not in the process of having to kill
first you're just really in you know
thanksgiving um a few moments of
appreciation simple things
the feel good that you experience the
love and kindness meditations these
kinds of things
we know based on neuroimaging studies
and blood draws and things of that sort
promote the release of things like
serotonin and oxytocin
that nature has designed beautiful
systems of pursuit
and
pleasure that are designed to oscillate
and designed to keep us in pursuit and
pleasure cycles in relationships
typically the dopamine phase is the
early phase simultaneously in these
cycles oftentimes not simultaneously
typically dopamine and serotonin are
released always there's always some
floating around our system at any moment
but typically dopamine and adrenaline
are associated with pursuit of things
that are outside the confines of our
immediate possession in our skin and
serotonin is more about the things that
we have the things you know get seeing
your kid holding your kid that promotes
the release of oxytocin and serotonin it
feels amazing right these are the
molecules that led to our evolution as a
species so
i'm not diminishing one or the other but
they need to oscillate right in early
relationship
there are times when people aren't
sleeping very much it's like a mental
illness it's like it's a form of mania
you're so excited you don't need sleep
right people are able to to do all sorts
of things at frequency and intensity
that they find themselves two years
later in a relationship
and they love the person it's very warm
and cozy but well unless they're going
off on deployments and coming back they
don't have that reset of the of the
system so
you know
the ability to miss somebody reset that
pursuit and desire system these are
powerful systems and they don't just
pertain to romantic relationships this
is also school i always you know i
always did summer school because i had
to do a lot of catching up to do based
on the
you know a lot of catching up but you
know there's some value in taking a week
off
and realizing you are truly resetting
all the systems for pursuit and i hear
from a lot of hard-driving folks who
like wow once i understood dopamine i
realized why i'm so burnt out people
think of adrenal burnout
guess what there's no actual medical
term adrenal burnout there's adrenal
insufficiency syndrome that's a rare
syndrome but you have enough adrenaline
packed away in your brain and body to
for three lifetimes think about what
people used to go through i mean you
talk about some of this on your podcast
you see the images of people and you
read the stories like you can make it
through finals kids
so
that what happens though is we're in
such modes of pursuit and overthinking
overthinking we need to learn how to
switch back and forth on a regular basis
what i call deliberate decompression or
non-sleep deep rest have a practice each
day of 10 to 30 minutes where you're not
on your phone and you're in kind of a
wordless state you're just either yoga
nidra or you're just relaxing or
not watching anything not taking in any
sensory information not meditating
not journaling just in a state of
just trying to blank your mind and just
watch how much stronger you come back in
terms of your ability to focus on your
motivation
that's one i love the phone and social
media has been very good to me and i
appreciate many of its features but one
of the problems is we tend to fill our
idle time with more sensory information
and that doesn't allow us to go into
this deliberate decompression it doesn't
allow us to
you remember i cut myself off but a
picture is worth a thousand words well a
movie is worth a million pictures now i
can scroll through millions of movies
very quickly and so the dopamine system
is just a little bit overwhelmed i don't
think we need to be off our phones all
the time we just take some time to just
deliberately decompress each day any
time of day
and you'll focus better so you're
getting hit with that dopamine on on
instagram so at first you are but here's
how you know
dopamine and it will give you a window
into addiction if you're if you're not
an addict you'll be able to sympathize
with maybe even empathize with addicts
of various kinds when you first get on
social media you're excited maybe you or
joe or somebody has a new podcast out
right you know you're excited i can't
wait to hear that's dopamine you're
motivated
but if you ever find yourself doing a
behavior and you kind of don't know why
you're doing it like this doesn't feel
any good anymore it's like that what is
that chris well now he's it's a funny
story there because new stuff but that
chris rock thing where he's talking
about like you know when you're shanking
somebody and your heart's just not in it
like that
he does this funny thing right i think
it was him you're still like that like
yeah your heart's not in like why am i
here why am i what am i doing i'm not
even getting any pleasure but here i am
like a you know rap pressing a lever
well
that's the dopamine system has been
depleted
and so what you need is some time away
from it could be 10 minutes could be 10
days
and then it feels good again
true for relationships true for exercise
you know i believe in training hard and
training often but if you train too hard
too often you can't bring the intensity
that you need to get the stimulus to
adapt and pretty soon you're either
plateauing or getting worse